at my dry cleaners and I'm going to go
inside and see how I do in Korea
here we are remember dry cleaner here
get it here dry cleaners & alterations
all right we're gonna walk in here and
yes I know I see all my guys they all
touchiness so counting yourself yeah
[ __ ] Oh John Cena's ooh hey hey
Tenenbaum cha Chi you go what's often
pants are you sick dance [ __ ] Heidi
yeah Papa some new car pick up my pants
here
Georgina say oh hey child genius simmer
down
Hey look okay so coumba how do i zoom de
ha ha yo Jimmy Yoshimi Chicka taehun
Google - boom chimp chimp important
Jimbo yeah whoa
and table enemy de chez vous how
cohesive enough Jimbo Jimbo ha ha ha
yeah male money money charisma are you
see me sir
hunga hunga coccyx wanna saw munjong la
Teja a boy Chosun Ilbo see moon I saw a
moon John Chase is tomatoey Paco they
did call the tiga Marilyn tano
Takai you call it shut up
dictionary you're doing it right
how'd you go there John Johnny Johnny
Joe there comes a family that money
money Toa - sha sha comes out well there
you have it
I'm starting my third week so I visited
my dry cleaner again I don't know that
my I think my Korean has improved you
can't tell from that brief exchange I
have had two conversations with tutors
which I tried to record with call
recorder but it didn't work out but I
will eventually show you those I'm
speaking I guess earlier than I would
normally do but I'm spending more time
than I normally would
today my about an hour and a half on
link reading articles from the Chosun
Ilbo newspaper primarily and then a lot
of time in the car I had meetings
downtown played hockey so perhaps
another hour or more maybe an hour and a
half listening to these patterns again
on the radio somebody said you know
could we see exactly what you do when
you study well what I do is I listen I
read I work on link saving words and
phrases - link and then I read on my
iPad and I kind of shown you that but I
may just show you again and some of
those things and if there's some
particular things you would like to see
of my study routine please let me know
and that's it for today the start of my
third week